j'ai une question à vous poser qu'est ce
que vous voudriez pour la chaîne qu'est
ce qui vous plaît qu'est ce qui vous
plaît pas alors je vous explique j'ai
envie de faire un petit état des lieux
on va faire une vidéo sans coupure son
montage sans rien je commence ça se
termine
un trop générique de fin on se remet à
réclame donc si je dis des petites
bêtises qu'ils soient accrochés bas je
couperai pas je mettrai pas en reste
dans le bouton m dans la nature alors je
vous explique pourquoi parce que comme
vous le savez on est dans la phase i
vous savez peut-être peut-être pas on
est dans la deuxième saison de la chaîne
ça fait donc pas bientôt fin deux ans
que je fais ma chaîne on est nombreux et
de plus en plus nombreuses nombreuses et
je suis super content et je vous
remercie énormément moment je fais la
vidéo on et 159 me lesquels qu'on a
gagné plus de cent mille abonnés en
moins d'un an cendras et c'est vraiment
très très coup je suis hyper content
méchante reine nour réfléchir à ce que
je vais faire et comment je vais
attaquer à partir de la troisième saison
qui va commencer en septembre 2019
ça m'est fait pareil pour la deuxième
saison je m'étais posé la question je
vous avais pas consulté je vous avais
pas demandé tiens qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
fasse de quelle manière si ça donc là je
vous pose la question de quelle manière
est ce que vous voudriez que la chaîne
évolue
moi j'ai mon idée je veux pas vous le
partagez parce que je vraiment votre
feedback est à prévoir si on a peu
raccord site piocher des idées à droite
à gauche
alors pour faire simple déjà on va
parler de tout
on va parler de tout ensemble il n'y a
pas de tabou on peut tout se dire pour
que soient constructifs ses buts
pour ma part je vous dis j'ai ma vision
de ce que je veux faire pour un peu de
quelle manière je me le faire quelle
manière de modifier parce que j'ai
toujours que les choses évoluent vous
qu'on reste pas dans du statique que
l'on s'ennuie pas ni moi ni vous sont
toujours du partage
alors je vous le dis vous pouvez marquer
votre commentaire en bas je vais
répondre à tous les commentaires en a un
ça changera je serai on a souvent
reproché tu réponds pas aux commentaires
ceci je sais je sais je sais je suis
vraiment désolé c'est pas que je veux
pas je les lis quasiment tous c'est
vraiment un manque de temps et là je
veux vraiment prendre le temps de vous
répondre pour qu'on puisse vraiment
échanger d'ailleurs je la mets de cette
vidéo en haut de la chaîne ans
vidéo découverte pour que puisse être vu
un maximum d'ailleurs pour qu'elle
puisse être vu au maximum je vous invite
à les céder tous dès maintenant tout de
suite vous pouvez y aller un pouce bleus
pour l'algorithme pour qu'on puisse la
voir qu'elles soient partagées plus vues
et mieux distribuer pour permettre de
faire avancer un peu l'histoire
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on change
on va déjà se concentrait déjà sur le
générique est ce que vous voulez qu'on
change le générique si oui est ce que
vous les génériques un peu plus court
est ce que vous voulez un format
différent
donc je vous laisse me marquer ça en bas
il dire ce que vous en pensez deuxième
point c'est un peu l'atmosphère générale
des vidéos est-ce que voilà tous qu'ils
soient plus fun plus funky est ce que
vous voulez une atmosphère un peu
particulière est ce que il ya un truc
qui vous plaît qu'est ce que vous pensez
du style de vidéo actuel qu'est ce que
vous pensez de de l'atmosphère de
l'ambiance générale est ce que vous
voulez que ce soit plus sur le fun - le
feu n'a pas pu toutefois ce je ne sais
pas trop dites moi comment vous le
trouvez puis qu'est ce que vous voudriez
qu'est-ce que vous verriez comme points
d'amélioration
troisième point le contenu le contenu
actuel c'est beaucoup de la découverte
de produits aussi de test et il ya
beaucoup d'événements dans lesquels je
vous emmène avec moi des coulisses
est ce que vous voulez plus de coulisses
plus de coulisses même de moi de mon
travail de ma chaîne en savoir plus sur
le studio sur tout un peu plus perso est
ce que ça vous intéresse je pense
notamment la vidéo sur le les
tremblements il y avait beaucoup de
questions j'ai fait cette vidéo on est
aujourd'hui plus de 190 milles vue sur
cette vidéo c'est assez hallucinant
pense qu'un truc extrêmement personnel
donc je me suis demandé ce que le truc
un peu plus personnelles sont des choses
que vous voulez qu'on partage est ce que
vous êtes je vous partage des choses est
ce que ça vous intéresse
oui non vous marquez tout ça également
est ce que vous voulez qu'on continue
dans la découverte va donner avec moi
dans les coulisses comme là et je suis
parti il ya quelques temps à new york à
barcelone et compagnie je vous fais
toujours faire une petite visite de ma
chambre d'hôtel est vrai qu'on est plus
d'un côté coulisses dont on va les voir
une marque est ce qu'on voit qu'on n'y a
plus dans les coulisses par exemple on a
été visité les bureaux de xiaomi il ya
quelques temps vous emmener avec moi
découvrir un peu leur nouveau bureau est
ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse ça avec
d'autres marques
on pourrait aller visiter samsung vous
pourrez aller visiter relâche pas y'a
plein de marques intéressantes
wyplosz probablement qui pourrait nous
ouvrir un bureau à voir avec eux
d'ailleurs si vous regardez pouvez me
dire si vous voulez on vient de chez
vous est ce que ça vous intéresserait
est ce que vous voyez un sens à ce que
ce côté coulisses ce côté un peu plus
backstage je le dis en français et en
anglais
est-ce que cela vous tente oui non vous
marque également sa autre point est ce
que vous voulez qu'on soit plus dans la
orientation un peu plus standard tiens
je vous présente aujourd'hui le nouveau
patron pro le volet festif et s'agrippe
aux états unis celle de la lumière et
des couleurs phare à titre d'exemple est
ce que vous voulez qu'on soit plus d'un
côté présentation et du coup un peu
moins de coulisses un peu moins d'intimé
plus de la présentation produit ou alors
à contrario est ce que ça coûte un peu
plus coulisses qui vous botte le côté
échangé le côté intimiste
alors ça c'est vraiment des points des
points importants et puis il ya un autre
point je vous dis effectivement il ya
des tests à des présentations de
différents types de produits il ya
beaucoup de smartphones parce que c'est
l'objet technologie tout le monde avec
soi donc c'est vraiment un tout chantier
qui est très intéressant parce que tout
le reste aux smartphones ça c'est
vraiment cool
les mondes connectés je parle également
de table edge par également
d'ordinateurs j'ai parlé un peu de riz
beauty de robotique de robotique
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse est-ce qui
s est sujet vous intéresse
et est-ce que vous verriez d'autres
sujets plus larges est ce que vous
voulez des tutos des astuces des astuces
sur instagram ça se fait beaucoup sur
facebook savoir comment faire si des
astuces pour netflix comment brancher
sont plus comment faire si comment faire
ça est-ce que c'est des choses qui vous
intéressent est-ce que vous verriez un
sens et est ce que vous devrez par
exemple que je sais pas moi une fois par
semaine on se fasse un tuto découverte
tient à écouter voilà je vous parle de
netflix par exemple comment faire si
comment faire ça comment avoir des flics
su s en france à voir il ya donc ça
c'est dit moi si les choses comme ça ça
pourrait vous intéresser
quoi d'autre je vous ai parlé un petit
peu de tous ces points après dites moi
vous est ce qu'il ya des choses
aujourd'hui que vous n'aimez pas sur la
chaîne des choses qui vous dérange des
choses qui vous posent problème d'une
manière générale
est-ce que des fausses par trop vite je
sais que des fois je parle un peu trop
vite on a l'impression de regarder le
temps doux des fois la vidéo en accéléré
je vous corrige ce point je sais est ce
qu'il ya des choses que qui vous posent
problème est-ce quelque chose que vous
aimeriez que je change d'une façon
générale voilà beaucoup faire un état
des lieux
on peut tout à plat on peut tout se dire
que ce soit constructif je veux pas des
trucs dans les commentaires ou ça
devient délirant et on s'assoit pas
constructif on peut tout se dire
j'aime ça j'aime pas ça pourquoi comment
et qu'est ce que je voudrais que ça
donne ultérieurement
je vous invite à marquer tout ça en bas
là on est à 6 minutes 14 de vidéos je
vous invite à me marquer tout ça vous
dit vraiment ce que vous en pensez je
vais laisser cette vidéo pendant
longtemps un peu
avant pour pouvoir avoir beaucoup de
change et être prêt pour septembre moi
je vous dis j'ai ma vision des choses je
vois vraiment ce vers quoi je veux aller
il ya aujourd'hui qui dans ce que je
fais il y a mince
j'aime pas ça j'aimerais changer ça
j'aimerais faire comme ça je suis pas
satisfait il ya des choses que
j'aimerais vous raconter différemment
mais bon ça je veux pas vous le dévoiler
aujourd'hui je veux déjà pas influencer
influer sur vos idées sur votre choix
sur ce que vous auriez à partager on
prend tout ça je vais bien le lire on va
bien on discute et on se fait un mélange
de tout et on se donne rendez vous d'ici
quelques mois pour voir le résultat
final en attendant restez rassurez vous
continuez y avoir du contenu 1 dès
demain il y aura une vidéo j'ai plein de
produits à vous présenter plein de
choses j'ai reçu énormément de choses en
bas et visiter plein de marques on va
voir page 2 y'a plein de lancement ça va
être vraiment hyper intéressant merci
d'avoir pris tant de regarder cette
vidéo c'est vraiment le jeu vous
sollicite un c'est vraiment très très
important que vous jouiez le jeu vous
remarquez ça que vous soyez abonné ou
pas abonné peu important on n'est pas en
train de jeu par la tour je sais qu'il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui regardent
et qui sont pas forcément abonnés qui
viennent de temps en temps tu regardes
pas forcément envie de pouvoir pas
forcément envie de s'abonner 60 ans
complètement
si vous voulez vous abonner ça me va
c'est que ça m'arrange je vous le cache
pas donc je vous invite à marquer tout
ça on en parle ensemble et puis comme ça
ça paraîtra de de faire avancer tout ça
fait je suis très heureux port avant de
feedback et je vous dise vraiment vous
répondre à tous alors je n'étais pas
dans leur mais je le gère voilà vous
embrasse
à demain ciao